wie kann es sein dass ein verurteilter
sexualverbrecher wieder vergewaltigen
kann wie kann es sein dass ein solcher
man sich nochmal ein neues opfer suchen
kann diese fragen müssen jetzt auf den
tisch deutschland hat eine neue
diskussion über sexualstraftäter grund
der traurige fall eileen 14 jahre alt
tod ihr killer
29 jahre alt ein bekannter
sexualstraftäter dessen erstes
sexualverbrechen mit 14 da hat er
versucht elfjährige zu missbrauchen
danach zehn jahre in der psychiatrie
dann raus frei und offenbar bereit für
sein nächstes opfer für aline wer hat in
diesem fall versagt
der teufel see in hessen ein beliebtes
ausflugsziel für spaziergänger ein
ruhiger see mitten in einem
naturschutzgebiet
und möglicher tatort eines grausamen
verbrechens bei dem leichnam den wir
hier in dem see gefunden haben handelt
es sich um
mehrere tage treibt die leiche der
14-jährigen eileen im wasser des teufels
e 300 kilometer von ihrem zuhause
entfernt
was ist geschehen wieso musste das junge
mädchen sterben donnerstag den 21 juli
verließ eileen hier in gottenheim gegen
18 uhr das haus ihrer eltern
sie wollte einen freund zu fuß einen
pulli vorbei bringen aber sie kam nie
wieder nach hause zurück um 16 uhr
verlässt aline ihr elternhaus in der
hauptstraße im knapp 3000 seelen ort
gottenheim der weg zu ihrem freund ist
kurz nur 200 meter trennen die beiden
voneinander eileen läuft die hauptstraße
entlang biegt in die bahnhofstraße ein
und klingelt im schul acker an der
haustür ihres freundes doch ihr freund
ist nicht zu hause eileen ist weg wir
können mittlerweile sagen
[Musik]
anhand der digitalen spuren das eileen
in einem fahrzeug
von gottenheim in richtung hessen
gefahren ist
wir können nicht sagen inwiefern sie
dort freiwillig mit vor wie sie ins
fahrzeug verbracht wurde das ist
momentan alles noch beim jetzigen frühen
stand der ermittlungen offen zehn tage
später finden die ermittler dann die
leiche des jungen mädchens im 300
kilometer entfernten teufelssee
nordöstlich von frankfurt am main wurde
eileen am teufelssee getötet oder
versuchte ihr mörder hier ihre leiche zu
verstecken unklar die arbeit der
rechtsmediziner gestaltet sich als
schwierig berlins körper trieb zu lange
im warmen wasser der dringend
tatverdächtige kein unbekannter der mann
der das mädchen getötet haben soll sitzt
schon in haft er soll ein vorbestrafter
sexualstraftäter seien im jahr 2007 hat
er versucht ein mädchen zu vergewaltigen
63 strafgesetzbuch in einem
psychiatrischen krankenhaus im
sogenannten maßregelvollzug
untergebracht nach seiner freilassung
steht alliance mutmaßlicher mörder fünf
jahre lang unter beobachtung im januar
wird diese aufgehoben nur sechs monate
später der grausame mord an aline das 14
jährige mädchen soll er über social
media kennengelernt haben alliance
mutmaßlicher mörder schweigt bisher zu
der grausamen tat
[Musik]
und bei mir jetzt rainer wendt chef der
deutschen polizeigewerkschaft ich grüße
herzlicher wind wie können wir alliance
familie erklären das ist angeblich so
wichtig war diesen jungen mann nach zehn
jahren aus der psychiatrie zu entlassen
und dann irgendwie wieder in die
gesellschaft zu integrieren
unsere strafrecht sieht nicht vor auch
gefährliche menschen ihr leben lang
hinter gittern zu halten nach zehn
jahren die entlassung ist nicht
ungewöhnlich
danach die sogenannte führungsaufsicht
ist ein programm des landes hessen wie
in jedem anderen land auch nach der
föderalismusreform ist die zuständigkeit
dafür in die länder übertragen worden
das ist eigentlich ein vorbildliches
programm das muss man sagen auch in
bezug auf andere länder hat es schon
sehr frühzeitig hier eine
führungsaufsicht installiert die sich
sehen lassen kann aber es zeigt sich
dass es natürlich auch in einem solchen
system schutzlücken gibt der rechtsstaat
sieht man nicht vor dass menschen hinauf
ewigkeit hinter gittern sind auch dann
nicht wenn sie gefährlich sind dafür
gibt es ja diese instrumente der
führungsaufsicht dass das nach fünf
jahren ausgelaufen ist ist das ergebnis
einer sachlichen prüfung die dann
stattgefunden das ist auch der regelfall
dass das nach fünf jahren ausläuft wenn
die person dann nicht auffällig geworden
ist der rechtsstaat sitten und einmal
vor dass jemand der dann seine strafe
entweder verbüßt hat oder gar keine
straftaten mehr begehen dann in freiheit
tatsächlich lebt das heißt eine tat wie
diese muss man in kauf nehmen dann muss
man nicht in kauf nimmt das bessere ist
der feind des guten auch und gerade im
bereich der führungsaufsicht wird viel
darüber diskutiert ist die qualifikation
unserer gutachter ausreichend die
bewährungshelferin und bewährungshelfer
sagen immer wieder dass es zu wenig
personal in diesem bereich gibt da gibt
es immer noch qualität zu verbessern das
bessere ist da immer der feind des guten
aber man kann nicht sagen dass wir von
einem schlechten system reden müssen und
schon gar nicht muss man sich irgendwo
mit abfinden also täuscht der eindruck
dass wir zu viel auf die täter schauen
zu großzügig sind zu sehr versuchen
diese männer wieder zu integrieren und
zu wenig an potenzielle neue opfer
denken wenn jeder fünfte rückfällig wird
jede fünfte wird rückfällig und jeder
der rückfällig wird ist einer zu viel
aber der rechtsstaat siethen einmal vor
dass wir uns auch alle mühe geben müssen
tatsächlich mit diesen personen von
denen eine gefahr ausgeht fertig da
können wir uns herr wendt genügend mühe
die opfer die potenziellen opfer zu
schützen wenn jeder fünfte rückfällig
ausdrücklich nein da geben wir uns nicht
genügten das zeigen ja immer die vielen
beschwerden auch diejenigen die
beispielsweise im strafvollzug tätig
sind und dort über personal marie klagen
das heißt zu wenig mit den menschen
machen können die dort hinter gittern
sitzen aber die antwort des
rechtsstaates kann nicht sagen alle von
denen eine gefahr ausgeht und ihr leben
lang einzusperren so große haftanstalten
gibt es gar nicht und deshalb muss man
außerhalb der haftanstalten alle
bemühungen tatsächlich verstärken und da
sieht noch viel potenzial noch es ist
nur so schwer zu verstehen dass jemand
der mit 14 eine solche grausamen tat
zumindest erstmals versucht an einer
elfjährigen dass der nach zehn jahren
psychiatrie tatsächlich bereit ist sich
wieder ganz normal zu integrieren es
schwer zu verstehen ist umso umso
wichtiger ist es dass in diesem bereich
größerer anstrengung vollzogen werden
das heißt in einfach nur raus zu lassen
und zu beobachten ist das eine das ist
notwendig polizei bewährungshilfe alle
tun da ihr möglichstes aber es muss
natürlich intensiv mit diesen personen
auch sie müssen sehr engmaschig betreut
werden wenn das denn gelingen soll und
hier ist es offensichtlich nicht
gelungen aber es gelingt in den
allermeisten fällen auch das muss dazu
jetzt wird dieser mann eine neue strafe
bekommen und dann irgendwann wieder
freikommen das ist nicht sicher zunächst
einmal muss eben jetzt die tat
nachgewiesen werden vor den beamtinnen
und beamten von staatsanwaltschaft und
polizei liegt jetzt eine menge arbeit es
ist ein
ermittlungsergebnisse eine person ist
festgenommen dringend tatverdächtigen
untersuchungshaft es spricht vieles
dafür dass diese personen die tat
begangen hat verurteilt ist er noch
nicht und es spricht auch vieles dafür
dass wenn danach der ersten tag weil er
ganz offensichtlich psychisch krank war
und deshalb nicht verurteilt wurde
sondern einer psychiatrie untergebracht
wurde das auch jetzt wieder passiert
sagt ihr herz der man darf nie wieder
frei kommt eigentlich ja dann gab meiner
band danke an den chef der deutschen
polizeigewerkschaft
und unser reporter hagen stegmüller ist
in gottenheim dem heimatort von eileen
in gottenheim hagen natürlich wut trauer
und sicherlich auch die frage wer hat
hier versagt
morgen vertriebs ja diese frage taucht
natürlich auch auf warum man muss ich es
sowieso vorstellen gottenheim ist ein
gesegneter ort bis vor einer woche gab
es hier wahrscheinlich nicht mal einen
diebstahl man hat hier einen blick auf
die vogesen der storch brütet noch auf
dem kirchturm darf man kennt sich von
vereinen die familie von eileen des hier
verwurzelt der vater wegen dem
gesangverein
eileen soll früher fußball gespielt
haben hat hier freunde gingen zur schule
und von heute auf morgen wurde diese
idylle zerstört und all das was eben
angesprochen wurde diese
fassungslosigkeit wut und trauer die ist
natürlich immens und wurde natürlich
auch dadurch noch einmal gesteigert dass
man gehört dass es sich um einen
vorbestraften
sexualstraftäter handelt und einfach die
frage ist immer wie kann das sein wie
darf das sein warum werden unsere kinder
nicht besser geschützt viele haben jetzt
auch selber angst um ihre kinder oder
enkel
es läuft aufs neue die diskussion
anlagen wegsperren für immer das ist ein
ganz besonderer fall ein junger mann der
mit 14 zum ersten mal so schwer
straffällig wird der im alter von 14
jahren seinen ersten missbrauch seine
erste sexualstraftat beginn bzw begehen
will ja wie welche antworten findet man
dort in gottenheim auf die frage
wegsperren für immer
man hat schon mehrere sachen ins spiel
gebracht zum einen natürlich das
klassische wegsperren wie kann einer so
war so jemand jemals wieder rauskommen
man diskutiert ja auch etwas über über
fußfesseln manche sagen
solche menschen müssen mit medikamenten
ruhig gestellt werden dass eben dieser
trieb der sich offenbar nicht weg
therapieren lässt dass der auf null
heruntergefahren wird sie wünschen sich
einfach antworten dass so etwas nie
wieder passiert aber unabhängig davon
allein ist natürlich tot und wir möchten
auch mal zeigen wie die menschen in
gottenheim trauern das rathaus sie hat
sich zu einer pilgerstätte entwickelt
seit sonntag am sonntag war auch schon
in der kirche oben ein gedenkort
eingerichtet hier kommen unablässig
menschen her und legen gedenkkerzen
nieder blumen es ist ein streng
katholische ort viele menschen
bekreuzigen sich davor sie fahren hier
mit dem auto weil es gibt keine dann
nicht den blick nach rechts dreht die
welt scheint in gottenheim für einen
moment still zu stehen
hagen stegmüller aus gottenheim vielen
herzlichen dank für deine schilderungen
[Musik]